la situación en pacmut es extremadamente
delicada y así lo confirmaba también
esta mañana al Ministerio de
inteligencia británico que hace un
seguimiento diario de la situación en el
donbas decía que la presión contra las
fuerzas y ucranianas es cada vez mayor y
hablaba de las dificultades para el
abastecimiento de las rutas de acceso
especialmente después de la destrucción
de dos puentes por los ucranianos mismos
uno de ellos fundamentales en esa ruta
de acceso desde la población de
chasiblar que era hacía como de pulmón
para las fuerzas que están en bacmut
pero también hablaban de que en las
últimas horas han habido refuerzos de
fuerzas especiales de ucranianas que han
llegado a apoyar a quienes defienden
esas posiciones sin embargo versiones
que vienen desde adentro nos cuentan que
los rusos siguen avanzando allí
especialmente en las poblaciones
cercanas que necesitan para acabar de
cerca a la población de vacunas y esto
sucede en un momento en el que se
conoció la visita del ministro de
defensa incluso a la región al donbad
ucraniano sergey estuvo allí y esto se
puede leer primero como un mensaje de
Victoria o de avance de las fuerzas
rusas que recordemos que hay que ponerlo
en contexto Rusia lleva peleando por la
población del pero especialmente de
bacmut desde el pasado agosto ha
invertido una gran capacidad de hombres
y también de de maquinaria militar Así
que tal vez no se puede leer como una
gran Victoria para ellos y también hay
que recordar que parte de esta batalla
ha sido liderada por los paramilitares
Wagner allí estaba su fundador días
atrás que ya daba parte de Victoria y
decía que la ciudad estaba prácticamente
rodeada pero ambas fuerzas tanto el
ejército como estos paramilitares han
estado en disputa durante las últimas
semanas y la presencia del ministro de
defensa Allí se lee también como una
golpe de fuerza para contrarrestar toda
este golpe de opinión y Pro paganda que
lanzan desde estos paramilitares